And I would like to introduce today,
Dan Valana manner.
He is a computational neuroscientist from
Ucla and today today he'll talk about
his book.
Your brain is a time machine,
which you can actually buy a
discounted price at this table.
And so that was for those
of you that comes in.
Thank you and thank you for all for
coming today. It's a pleasure to be here.
So I'd like to talk a bit about time and
the brain and the brain and the nature
of time.
And to get my talk started,
I'd like to start by creating a
awkward silence. Um, and I'd like
to do that to make three points.
The first is that your
brain is automatically
attempting to predict what is
about to happen.
Your brain as a prediction machine.
So right there you are trying to
predict what's was about to happen.
Maybe you're thinking, oh, he's having
an absence seizure. Um, number two,
your brain is automatically telling time.
The only reason you could notice that
pause is because you're creating a
temporal expectation of the normal
average pause between words and that bio,
that temporal pause was violated.
And that's when the passage of time came
to your attention and that's my point
number three,
you probably became aware of the passage
of time you the subjective feeling of
time going slowly because
it was a slightly awkward
moment and I'm time probably
seemed to be going
slowly and hopefully um,
it wasn't as long as it seemed to be,
at least I hope it wasn't because
to me it seemed like a full minute.
But before we delve in to the mechanisms
of how the brain tells time in the
meaning of the nature of time,
let me for already start off by pointing
out that I've used the word time a
number of times in this talk already and
I assume you know what I mean and I s
and you assume I know what the word
means, but isn't that the case? Do we,
can we actually define time?
It turns out, I'm sorry, here,
let me get used to clicking this.
It turns out that the word time is the
most common noun in the English language
along with two others that are
units of time, year and day.
So on. This is an obvious indication
of how important time is in our lives.
Um,
but it's a bit ironic that the most
common noun in the English language is one
that we really can't define. It's been
embarrassing action, isn't it? Um,
so this brings us to the problem.
How do we define time?
And people have struggled with
this for a long, long time. So,
um, a thousand, 600 years
ago, Saint Augustine said,
what then is time if no one asks me,
I know what it is.
If I wish to explain it to me,
what you asks, I do not know. Um,
a thousand, 600 years later, the
great physicist Richard Fineman,
who's not wanting to give up easily on
problems, basically gave up and said,
maybe it's just as well we faced the
fact that time is one of those things we
probably cannot define what matters
anyways is not how we defined time,
but how we measure it.
Um,
but it was probably the author Douglas
Adams that gave us the most important
definition of time. Time is an
illusion. Lunchtime. Doubly so.
Um,
so part of the problem is that the word
time really means different things.
Right? And let me give you this rather
contrive sentence to make that point.
Einstein's talk on the nature of time,
um,
started on time but seem to
last a long time. Um, okay.
So first the nature of time,
so that refers to the physics of time
is time a full blown dimension as in um,
the four dimensions of time is only
the present, uh, exist is time.
A abstraction that we scientist used
to help us understand the universe.
Second started on time.
That's clock time.
That's the easiest time to define right.
That's um,
time is defined as what clocks town
as circular as that definition is.
It's a really useful one and probably
the most important in that it got all of
us here on time. Um, the last one
is the subjective feeling of time.
So it seemed to last a long time and um,
that's tightly linked law on linked
to the problem of consciousness.
So in that sense,
the subjective sense of time is also
a very difficult problem to address.
Now starting with the first question,
um,
the brain is,
time is really important
to how the brain works. So,
and this is why I consider in many
ways the brain to be, if you will,
a time machine.
And there's four reasons for that.
The brain is a machine that tells time,
the brain generates the subjective
feeling of the passage of time,
the brain attempts to predict the future.
The brain is a remembers the past
in order to predict the future.
And finally the brain allows us
to project ourselves mentally,
mentally project ourselves into the pastor
of the future is something we called
mental time travel. And this
is really important for, um,
our ability to interact with the world
in terms of what's makes humans unique is
our ability to engage
in mental time travel.
And we'll talk a bit more about this,
but first, consider the first issue here.
The brain is a time machine.
So the brain tells time across 12 orders
of magnitude from microseconds at the
lower end over there too. Um, down here,
which you're using right now
to four sound localization.
So your brain picks up
the tens or hundreds of
microseconds delays it takes to
sound to arrive from my left ear to my
writing by picking up the Delta t's,
the relative time, delays their
time, perception in speech,
um, eyes on the order of hundreds
of milliseconds and seconds. Music,
motor coordination is happening
on this range of time perception.
And we'll delve more into that and
then we have time estimation, um,
which is sort of what most people think
of when we talk about their sense of
time. How long has, um, how
long has this talk been lasting?
How long has the light red light
been waiting to change and so forth.
And find the,
you have your circadian rhythms and that
everybody's familiar with in terms of
controlling your clock, when to get out
in the morning and went to go to bed now.
So how does the brain tell time?
So to answer that question,
it's useful to think about timing
and these different scales. So,
for example,
in language,
a couple of examples here are if I say
something like they gave her cat food or
they gave her cat food, right? So there
you're using the pause and speech, um,
to determine this, the content of the
meaning of the sentence. And by the way,
this is something that artificial
speech, um, systems, um,
still struggle with a bit.
This is one of the challenges and it's
because of some of the mistakes that I'm,
there's still made even with
the most advanced systems.
Now another example here is in music.
And now I'm going to play
to you a piece of music.
And the task here is it's a hybrid piece
of music and see if it reminds you of
anything.
But the time has been altered.
And I know some of you are here at the
beginning and you probably saw the next
slide here. So you're going to
have to keep quiet. But, um,
Google please play music here.
So does this remind you of any
piece of music you know of?
So I'll give you a hint.
You guys are young crowd,
but it's from a group called the
Beatles. Um, does it remind anybody?
Does that ring a bell to anybody? Can
anybody pick up what that was? Yup.
Okay. Very good. Anything else? Anybody
else pick the reminder? Any other song?
So that's a hybrid song there.
So what that was was the notes.
So you're paying more attention to the
notes. The melody of I'm yellow submarine,
but it was the timing of yesterday.
So we sort of did a hybrid crossing of
the spatial information and the temporal
information. So sometimes people pick
up a bit more on the temporal structure.
Sometimes people pick
up more on the melody.
But this is just to make the obvious
point that without time and ability to
perceive and to tell time,
um,
music of course wouldn't exist.
And indeed it's in this scale of tens
to hundreds of milliseconds that time.
Is that, um, most important.
So in the context of the lab,
for example,
one question we ask is whatever mechanisms
are they in your brain that allow you
to tell time, can they
improve with practice? Um,
so we often ask in studies where we do
an interval discrimination studies to
tell us what is the first or second
interval, the longest Google,
please play music.
So there's a simple intervals,
discrimination task. And the question is,
was the first or second longest?
And the first was a hundred milliseconds
and the second interval was 150
milliseconds.
Now if you have some timer in your
brain that's fixed like a watch,
maybe it doesn't matter,
maybe you can't get better at that.
But if you practice and
that timer improves,
then you should be able to pick that up.
And we do,
and we can tell here that
in the 100 millisecond case,
that's what you just heard. People
improved dramatically with practice.
But interestingly, if you had a clock in
your brain that was your master clock,
you'd also get in that
clock was somehow improving.
You should get better at all intervals.
So you should also get better
at 50 millisecond interval
of the 200 millisecond
interval or the 500 millisecond. But you
don't. So this is a bit strange, right?
It's almost as if you have
multiple clocks in your brain,
you have an array of different clocks
that can tell time across different time
ranges.
So how does the brain do that?
Or where in the brain does the brain,
um,
what parts of the brain responsible
for timing. Fortunately,
we know exactly what part of the brain
tells time and that's this part right
here, right beside locality and
music conveniently located. Um,
this of course is nonsense.
Um, but this friend,
a logical view of time never lasts,
is surprisingly influential, um,
in how people think about times.
So people do still think about time,
even today in the sense that you might
have a central clock in your brain.
So the office of this faculty is to
mark the passage of time, duration,
succession of events, et Cetera.
It ultra remembers dates,
keeps correct time and music and dancing
and induces to punctuality in the
fulfillment of engagement.
So this is an extreme view of what you'd
call a central clock or a master clock
in your brain.
We know that this is not correct.
The brain has multiple ways to tell.
Time is multiple areas in the brain
that are involved in telling time.
So understand how the brain tells time.
Let's first remind ourselves how
man made clocks actually work.
So manmade clocks,
um,
despite their complexity all work for
the most part under an embarrassingly
simple principle.
And that's just an Oscillator,
your time base and a counter.
So whether you're talking about a
pendulum clock or a quartz crystal,
or even an atomic clock in which you're
using the period of the electromagnetic
vibrations, um, to tell time,
you're just counting the ticks of an
oscillator. So it's reasonable to ask,
is that how the brain tells time?
The answer is no.
So as quote from Einstein reminds us,
any physical phenomenon may be used
as a clock provided it can be exactly
repeated as many times as desired.
So here we have raindrops
falling on a pond.
And if I asked you which
raindrop fell first,
the up one over here or down here,
you could tell me this
raindrop fell first.
And if we were so inclined
and knew a bit of physics,
we could even calculate the interval.
So the point is is that even this
static image has information about time.
And that's because physical systems
that have dynamics naturally tell time.
I mean that's essentially what dynamics
is. Dynamics is the change in time.
So the idea is is that the brain uses
its own dynamics as one way to tell time.
So neurons
are the computation element of the brain.
And neurons have their axons,
they have, I'm sorry, they have their
dendrites and the axons down here,
the axons of one neuron can come over
and synapse on the dendrites of another
neuron.
And that's where they make a synapse.
It releases transmitter here and creates
a bioelectrical signal that travels
towards the Soma of the
postsynaptic neuron.
So if you have these elements and
they're connected to each other,
one way we could make a time or clock,
if you will,
is to connect them in a chain.
So if we had one neuron that was connected
to another, connected to another,
connected to another,
we can now see that we'll have this
temporal pattern of activity in which one
neurons activates the next, activates
the next, next, I mean it's the next.
So you know that if this neuron is active,
that eight or nine,
10 units, um, time units have elapsed.
So indeed it seems that one way the
brain tells time on the scale of tens to
hundreds of milliseconds to
seconds is through neural dynamics.
Um, and we know this in
part due to research, um,
on a number of studies on both humans
and animals and one animal that knows how
to time very well our songbirds. So these
are zebra finches and um, they sing,
and I won't play you their song here,
but this is the spectrogram
of a zebra finch song.
And I'm not too different from speech
in which this is our frequency access.
This is of course time and these
are the syllables of the song.
And they can sing this hundreds and
hundreds of time pretty faithfully,
where you could almost overlay
each song on top of each other.
When scientists record from neurons
in an area of the Zebra finch brain,
um, they can record from
many different neurons.
So here the recording from 136 neurons,
and here we're just showing the activity
when those neurons spike and aligning
them in time.
And so some neurons spike early on,
some neurons spike later and so forth.
So you have sort of this chain of
activity in which seems to be the brain's
clock for the song at least.
So some neurons telling it's
the beginning of the song,
middle of the song and so forth.
So you have these complex patterns,
neural dynamics.
Now in a more complex network,
and this is a simulation here. Um, and
normally I wouldn't show the simulation,
but here because I'm at Google and
there's a strong interest in on AI and
machine learning.
I'll give you an example of a simulation
of a recurrent neural network in which,
um, you're simulating neurons and these
neurons are connected to each other.
And, um, actually curl,
I'm going to act, I forgot.
There's one more s button I'm going to
have to ask Google depressed in a minute.
Um, so, um, and when you do this,
this network is going to do um,
a speech recognition task,
a speech transcription task.
So the network will listen to a spoken
degette and then transcribe that pattern
in time. So can Google, can you
still start that movie please?
So what you'll see here,
I'll show point over here.
So that's the spectrogram and this is
the activity in the neural network.
So this is the activity of different
neurons and this is driving that activity.
And that activity here is driving.
So there's not much hidden here.
Unlike say a deep learning network, which
drives a lot of series power. Of course,
this is the whole thing
happening right here.
This network is driving this
and processing this stimulus.
There's around 4,000 units in this.
So in contrast,
a deep network in which
you have millions. So, um,
that was an fast eight in
the next eight will be slower
a.
So that was a slower eight.
And the point here is that by encoding
time in these trajectories in the
dynamics of these neural networks,
it naturally solves the problem of
what we call temporal and variants.
The issue of how you can
recognize a song or speech,
whether it's spoken very
quickly or very slowly.
So overall,
as far as we know,
one of the major computational strategies,
the brain has to process
time varying information,
which is most of the information you'd
passing right now. Speech of course,
is through neural dynamics,
sister changing patterns of activity.
Now
we all know that whatever the clocks
that are within our brain is sometimes
they're accurate,
inaccurate.
So there's a mismatch between
objective time and subjective time.
And um,
this leads to temporal illusions or
temporal distortions everybody's familiar
with, with, um, time flies
when you're having fun.
And to go back to a quote from
Henry James, which was, um,
from his magnum opus principles of
psychology or in over a hundred years ago,
he says in general,
a time filled with varied and interesting
experiences seems shore in passing,
but long as we look back, on
the other hand, attractive time,
empty of experiences seems long in
passing. But in retrospect, short,
so some people refer to this as
the vacation paradox. You're,
you're having fun in eighth and in
Athens for the first day and um,
you're seeing a lot of new sites,
meeting New People and time
seems to fly by prospectively.
So as it's happening,
as it's playing out prospectively,
um,
your estimates of time are on the,
a short amount of time has elapsed even
though it might have been a long period
of time. But retrospectively,
as you look back,
that's not so much a timing task,
but a memory task.
You're thinking of back of the number
of items or you're influenced by the
number of items in memory. So if you
have it filled day in which a lot of, um,
interesting things were happening,
you're going to have a lot of memories
of that event and left with the
impression that it was a long period
of time. Elapsing now in contrast,
if you're bored or anxious, then, um,
as time is going by prospectively,
um,
you might overestimate the amount of time
it seems like a lot of time has been,
I'm going by,
so you're stuck at the airport and um,
you're on a six hour wait because of
a plane delay and time is dragging,
right?
You're bored out of your
mind retrospectively when
you look back upon your trip,
that's merely merely a blip
in your conscious experiences.
Right? So because, um,
you know, the Atlanta bathroom is
only so interesting and it didn't, um,
store too much information about
that wonderful experience, um,
in your memory banks.
So you have,
we have this paradox between prospective
timing in retrospect of timing, which,
um, in part influences our
ability to tell time. Now,
everybody has also known about cases
under sort of extreme danger or um,
extreme stress situations in which people
report time actually slowing down or
things happening in slow motion.
And um,
so this is a report of a
race car driver who, um,
was whose car was thrown into air,
spun around in the air.
He obviously survived and um,
later gives this report.
It seemed like the whole
thing took forever.
Everything was in slow motion
and it seemed to me like
I was a player on a stage
and could see myself tumbling
over and over in the car.
It was as though I sat in the
stands and saw it all happening.
So here obviously it's not only their
impression of the passage of time that is
being altered right space as well.
I think this is probably best
described as an hallucination.
So this is an altered state,
um,
in which our sense of time and sense
of body sense of space has been
dramatically altered.
So I think this,
the mystery here is not so
much what happens these states,
but what happens in the normal strength
that gives us or our impression of the
passage of time now disability to tell
time and perceive the passage of time,
estimate how much time has elapsed
is not unique to humans in any way.
Um, all animals are, most
animals certainly have the
sense of the time of day.
They know they have circadian clock,
they can learn when food will
arrive, um, and so forth.
What is unique and humans,
however,
is probably our ability to engage
in what we call mental time travel.
So we can think about the past and relive
our memories and we experience things
that we have already experienced.
Um,
and sort of study that,
right? We can learn,
we can reimagine a conversation we had.
We can give it alternate endings to
test out whether we should have said
something different, um, or
not. But even more importantly,
we can imagine the future.
We can project ourselves into the future
and simulate the future in our heads.
And some people believe that this is
indeed why consciousness involved evolved,
so the consciousness,
a way to simulate the future and and
this is what makes humans humans, right?
Whether it's your ability to the first
person to carve a knife or a weapon out
of an obsidian stone must
have had something in mind.
What am I going to use this for?
So this ability to think about what this
will be used for in the future seems to
evade the ability of most animals.
So you take one of the most important
inventions of humankind agriculture,
right? It's a hard concept and
we take for granted, right?
I'm going to plant something now and
reap its benefits that are going to
guarantee survival a year from now.
This ability to link sure to link cause
and effect actions across large Delta
t's long periods of time
is very unique to humans.
I've always wondered if if humans are
only the only species that have figured
out the relationship between
sex and pregnancy, right?
That's a fairly long period of time
to just can other animals grasp that
relationship because it spans
periods of weeks or months.
Now looking into the
future can be a bummer,
right?
Because the first humans to really see
the future in rasp saw something they
probably didn't like. Right. And,
um, this might have been, by the way,
a good time to invent religion
when you first started.
See understanding what the future
holds. And I think this point is, um,
beautifully made by, um, harsher Luis,
but barges to be a mortal is
common place except for man,
all creatures are immortal
for their ignorant of death.
So certainly seeing into
the longterm future, um,
is what characterizes our
species in many ways. Um,
but it also has,
um,
affect our culture in many ways and
how we cope with what we've seen now.
Um,
just because humans are uniquely able,
and I'm sorry, there's a quantity.
One more button I'm going to need pressed
over there for the next movie. Um,
I didn't look far enough into the
future to anticipate this. Sorry. Um,
so,
um,
just because human beings are uniquely
able to engage in mental time travel,
it doesn't mean we're actually
particularly good at it. Right. And, um,
so learning to delay gratification and
learning to withhold immediate rewards
for,
um,
longer term benefits is something
our species is uniquely able to do.
But it's also something we struggle with.
So here's the gratuitous child,
cute baby video of the talk.
You can start that please.
And this is the famous marshmallow
experiment on that plane.
Doesn't look like it's going to play
here. Um, oh, we're probably okay.
Just pride pressing.
Enter something there.
That's okay. We'll do it without it. Um,
we'll do it with do without the gratuitous
video of kids eating marshmallows.
Um,
so the marshmallow experiment,
as many of you probably know,
is an experiment in which they say they
get four or five year olds in saying,
okay, here's one marshmallow. Um,
you can eat it now or you can wait until
I come back and then you're going to
get two marshmallows. And, um,
this ability to delay gratification is
indeed part of what it means to grow up,
to be able to withhold your immediate
gratification, um, for later reward.
And these studies later
showed these studies by, um,
alter Michelle at Stanford.
Um,
that started in the 70s,
and he later track down many of these
children and he found a correlation,
a weak correlation,
but correlation nevertheless
with their ability to withhold,
to wait to withhold gratification,
um,
at the young age with later on sat scores.
Um,
so there's indeed there's many pieces
of evidence that there's a correlation
between what we call temporal discounting
or ability to postpone or patients
with, um, with health
issues as well. So, um,
the
major issue there of course is that much
of what we do is contingent upon our
understanding that what we do now has
consequences in the future and going to
school, saving for retirement, um,
exercising are all things that we take
for granted but are implicitly contingent
on our understanding of
temporal relationships, right,
of longterm temporary relationships.
But many of the problems
we face as individuals and
as members of society arise
from not doing that well enough temporal
myopia. So personal credit card debt,
exercising uni healthy,
not saving enough for retirement
or things at the individual level,
which we struggle with in order to
balance our short term gratification with
long term rewards.
At the more,
I'm not at the sort of societal
levels fader to adjust climate change,
underfunded pension plans,
national debt are things that a societal
level or merge in part because of our
failure to take appropriate actions in
the present to assure or guarantee a
better quality of life or
health in the future. Now
humans as a sin are uniquely able
to think about the longterm future.
So how did that come about?
What's unique about the human brain that
gives us the ability to understand the
fundamental difference between
the past, present, and future,
and to plan for months,
years, or even decades ahead?
So some people have argued that we do
that in part because of our ability to
talk in language and because of the,
uh,
and use language and our brain's ability
to coopt to the parts of the brain that
are used to understand space.
The idea is,
is that there's areas in the brains of
most mammals that allow them to navigate
and understand space in
a manner of speaking.
And maybe the human brain co-opted
those same structures, um,
to allow us to understand time.
And one argument in favor of this is
that a lot of the ways we talk about time
is by using spatial men metaphors.
So I might say it was a long day or I'm
looking forward to the clips or you're
thinking,
I hope this talk shortly.
So we're using spatial metaphors
to talk about time and um,
so,
um,
this idea of the spatialization of time
is really one of the main ways we talk
and discuss, um, and understand time.
And another way to exemplify this is
with what we call the Wednesday question.
So I'll say our Wednesday meeting
was moved forward two days,
what day is our meeting on
Monday or Friday?
So there's no right or wrong answer there,
but it does reflect two different
perspectives we have about time.
So if you view time as sort of fixed and
you're the one walking through time and
you're moving,
then you'd say you move something
forward and from Wednesday it might go to
Friday. That's sort of what we
call an ego moving perspective.
But if we have a time moving perspective,
you're probably in the Monday group
in which your static and like a river
flowing time is like a river
flowing towards you and
that then the meeting would
be on Monday. So there's these
two different perspectives
that people have, uh,
have about time and they just reflect
the ambiguity of language and the fact
that we spatialized
time within our brains.
Um,
now this idea of the spatialization of
time that time is laid out in space is,
is very deep in the philosophical
literature as well as in physics because
there's sort of two diverging theories
as to the true nature of time.
One is precisely this,
that time is a dimension,
much like space.
So this is called eternalism and
internal ISM under eternal wisdom.
The past,
the present and the future are all equally
real now is perfectly arbitrary now
as our,
as arbitrary as here,
just like here is a perfectly
valid point in space to be,
I'm perfectly fine with you being over
there in time now is arbitrary and I
should be perfectly fine in internal ism.
Time is not always perfectly arbitrary.
And other versions of me or other
versions of you if you will,
are at past moments or present moment.
So everything is equally real and
I'm under presentism in contrast,
and this is sort of the more intuitive
sense we have in that only the present is
real.
So the past was real.
Some configuration of the universe that
we call past and now exists on the inner
memories is real, was real, the
present is real in the future.
Some configuration of the universe at
some future point will become real based
on what's happening in the present.
So of course it Turnell ism sort of
justifies a talk or a debate about whether
time travel is possible. Does nothing
to do with the physics of time travel,
whether you can actually do it or not.
But it Turnell ism justifies the debate
because at least there's moments in time
that exist that you could potentially
try to travel to under presentism.
The talk of time travel is a moot
point because there's nowhere to go.
There's no wind to go to be more precise.
Um,
now it terminal ism is sort of to the
degree that there is a standard view in
physics is the standard view.
And this is in part because of
Einstein's theory of special relativity.
So let me just try to convey, I find, um,
I find presentism to meet
be much more intuitive.
I think it's more consistent
with our experience,
but we believe in eternal wisdom,
at least in the physical
sense for very good reasons.
So let me try to convey those reasons
or one of those reasons. So to do this,
let me go over a thought experiment,
an Einsteinian thought experiment in
which we have the following set up.
We have an observer on a stationary
platform and a train going by and a
ludicrously impossibly
fast speed of two thirds.
The speed of light 0.6,
seven times the speed of light.
There's an individual in the middle of
the train that's shooting these space age
bullets towards the front
and the back of the train.
Now if you're this individual,
it doesn't matter because of the laws
of physics and relativity that you're
moving or not.
So you're going to shoot the bullet
forward and the sh bullet backwards,
and those bullets have to travel
the same distance at the same speed.
So this pane of glass will break at
the same time as that pane of glass.
Now,
okay,
so this person should observe that plane
of glass breaking at the same time as
this person was.
Now here you're the observer and you're
going to see the train traveling at a
high speed.
You're going to see this bullet traveling
in the opposite direction at the same
speed. So this bullet we'll have speed
zero will have a loss of the zero.
So basically this bullet will be going,
um,
we'll just be standing in mid air as the
back of the train runs into the bullet.
Okay?
That's pretty straightforward.
Now this forward bullet should be going
at the speed of the bullet plus the
speed of the train.
Now the speed of the bullet
is two thirds speed of light.
The speed of the train is
two thirds speed of light.
So the sum of those is 1.3
times the speed of light.
Okay? That's a no, no. Right? We
can't go faster than speed of light.
That's why Einstein told us.
So there's something goofy
that's going to happen here.
This bullet can't be traveling
as fast as it needs to be.
Going to break this pane
of glass at the same time.
So we see the bullet in motion approaching
the panes of glass and the person on
the train will observe both
panes breaking at the same time.
There'll be breaking simultaneously,
but the person on the stationary train
on the stationary platform will not see
that happen and it has nothing to
do with delays or the time it takes
information to get from here to there.
Okay?
This is just based on all
those adjustments and delays
being taken into account.
So this person will observe a different
reality while this person has a reality
in which both pre panes of glass break
at same time for this person's reality,
this, there'll be a moment in time
where this is broken, but that is not.
So this is taken as an argument.
This lack of absolute simultaneity is
taken an argument for the block universe
or for eternalism.
So why is that?
So let me give it again, run that
through you with this example here.
So let's look at this sort of our mini
block universe with four dimensions.
But we're going to own the plot to
instead of the three spatial dimensions,
we only have one. And we have this
temporal dimension dimension. So the,
for the person on the train,
this is their plane of simultaneity.
There's a moment where both panes of
glass at the back of the chain and at the
front of the train are both intact.
There's another moment in
exactly the same moment.
We're both panes of glass break.
Then there'll be another moment in time
where both glad panes of glass are ultra
already bumpkin. So these are
the planes of simultaneity, um,
for the person on the train. Now
the person on the platform, um,
the, in reality, the person
on the platform is, is,
is in our analogy not moving,
which is the same thing as from the
perspective of the person on the train.
That person on the platform is
moving in the opposite direction.
So if we just for reasons here, this is
going to be easier to explain that way.
So the person on the platform is sort of
traveling in the opposite direction of
the person on the train.
Now these planes of simultaneity don't
match up for the person on the platform.
So the plane of simultaneity,
special relativity,
Einstein's theory of special relativity
tells us that these moments will be the
same on these persons clock.
So there'll be a moment where the front
pain is not broken in the back one is.
So the point is is that
it's as if the universe,
everything that can happen
has already happened.
And the reason some things appear
simultaneous for one person and not for
another is a question as perspective.
So here the idea is is from
this person's perspective,
these events are aligned
but not for this person.
So this is one of the arguments for it
to journalism or the block universe.
Now there's a clash here,
right? If this is true,
it sort of leaves our impression of the
flow of time as an illusion because if
everything has already happened,
the clear subjective feeling that time
is flowing would seem that it has to be
an illusion, a certain sense. And, and um,
physicists have long been aware of this.
So this seems,
this is a quote from Roger Penrose.
It seems to me that there's a severe
discrepancy or there's serve your
discrepancies between what we consciously
feel concerning the flow of time and
what are theories assert about
the reality of the physical world.
It's another good quote by Herman Veil,
a physicist from the mid 19 hundreds.
The objective world simply is it does
not happen only to the gays of my
consciousness crawling upward
along the world line of my body.
Does the section of the world come
to life as a fleeting image in space,
which continuously changes in the time.
So they're getting to this issue that the
illusion that the flow of time must be
an illusion.
So this severely clashes with the
neuroscience of time and she clearly sees
fields that the subjective
experience of time is flowing by.
Um,
now
the question is, is if this is consistent
with our experience of consciousness,
now we don't really know
what consciousness is.
So this is a very difficult
question to, uh, to address.
But consciousness probably isn't what it
seems to be in the sense that it seems
to be providing a linear narrative of
what's happening in the world around us.
Rather,
the unconscious mind seems to be creating
this narrative in chunks and then
feeding this into the conscious mind or
creating the conscious mind, if you will,
um,
to create a convenient and
apparent flow of what's happening.
So there's a couple of
illusions that show this.
It's a bit of a hard concept to explain,
but let me just try to give
you a quick example here.
I'm going to say two sentences and just
pay attention to the meaning of the
sentences. So the first sentence is
the mouse pad was beside the computer.
Second sentence,
the mouse was hungry.
So in both of sentences, the meaning of
the word mouse was very different. Right?
So I think you're able to
understand that in the first case,
the mouse referred to an object, um, the
computer pad, mouse pad, and the second,
um, you know, to erosion,
but the meaning of mouse could only be
determined by the words that came after.
You can't impossibly interpret
that sentence in real time.
The mouse pad or the mouse was hungry.
So what comes after has to influence
your interpretation of what came before.
So this is one of the lines of evidence
that suggests that our conscious
experience is not so much a continuous
linear flow of the world around us,
but of a creation that is generated
in sort of fits and bursts of,
um, of interpretation of
what's happening around us.
So it may be the case
that our understanding of
consciousness may or may not be
compatible with the
standard view in physics.
I think Steven pinker was,
was hinting at this when he stated
matter is extended in space,
but consciousness exists in time as surely
as it proceeds from I think too, I am.
So we have to decide and
I think physicists and
neuroscientists to collaborate
more to decide if we should view our
subjective sense of the passage of time as
an empirical observation
about the universe.
One that has to be explained by physics
or if it's an illusion in the deepest
sense of the world and thus one that
doesn't have to be explained by physics,
but then has to be
explained by neuroscience.
How does the brain generate the conscious
subjective feeling of something that
has no correlation in the physical
world that is of the flow of time now,
um, to address these questions,
I think we have a long way to go.
And neuroscience is a very unique field,
neuroscience,
so unique field in all of sciences
because neuroscience is the only field in
which the Oregon or the thing being
studied is also doing the study.
And this raises a couple of potential
concerns, right? And not least of which,
well, and is that even possible?
Can something understand itself?
It's of course, way too early to
say to answer that question. Um,
but as scientific fields evolve,
as they mature,
part of that maturation process
is to progressively embrace time.
You look at, um, what I would consider
the first field of modern science, uh,
geometry. Geometry is formalized
by Euclid 2000, 300 years ago. Um,
it was highly influential
and transformative.
But why was it the first field of science?
Well,
it was the first field of science because
science is easier if you can ignore
time. That's what geometry is, right?
Geometry is the study of space and
objects that don't change in time.
It was on the round 2000
years after Euclid when, um,
people such as Galileo and Newton came
along and fully integrated time into time
and dynamics into physics.
Same thing in biology.
You think about biology up in 17 hundreds,
most of the 18 hundreds.
It was largely texts a, not tech,
sonic, economic and fairly static.
And then Darwin playing the
role of Galileo said, hey, um,
species are dynamic. They change,
they adapt, they evolve in time.
I think neuroscience is only reaching
this renaissance now where it's fully,
I'm beginning to embrace time and
realize that the brain is in a sense a
temporal Oregon. It's a time
machine, if you will. It tells time,
it remembers the past
to predict the future.
It allows us to mentally time travel
and creates the subjective sense of the
flow of time.
So elucidating how the brain tells time
represents and conceptualize this time
is critical to understanding the human
mind and the nature of consciousness.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
all right.
Have a question
or several gear. Yeah. Uh, yeah.
First question, it's about the,
your claim that humans are unique pay in
the sense that the week I'm foreseeing
the future,
but there has been a lot of studies in
I most like spitting on monkeys where
they can plan for the day,
whether they're going to do that.
They wake up every morning and they,
they go and get some fixed.
If they don't go for the things,
they will just stay awake later. Um,
so it's, it's kind of like weak
argument with the ugs made it.
What sense do you,
it's called mental time travel.
And the debate about whether other animals
can engage in mental time travel is
an active one.
What's there's no debate about is the
extent to which humans can engage in
mental time travel.
So no other animal can talk about plans
five years in the future because no
other animals can conceive or can
communicate about that. But interestingly,
the best animal data and the possibility
of Thai of mental time travel in the
animals, it's not for monkey.
So the monkeys data is
fairly debated. The people,
the major test people use there is if
monkeys can learn to use money because
monkey money is something that
implicitly requires. This has no value.
This has no value, right?
Paper has no value.
It only has value because I assume that
in the future I can exchange it for
something better. So they
tried to teach monkeys, apes,
great apes to use money by changing for
tokens and they can sort of get it to
hang. But this is highly debated. But
so that data's still controversial,
but the best data actually
comes from birds. Um,
and there's corvids scrub jays
that the best argument comes from.
They can seem to, if they're all in, oh,
always exposed to one part
of their [inaudible] area
in the morning and one part
in the afternoon.
They seem that they can plan ahead by
putting the food in the part of the
morning, a varium, um, and
not in afternoon name. So
this is an active field,
the debate. Um, but um,
part of the debate is,
is just one of extent. Um,
and humans clearly can,
can cross years and centuries
now other animals can.
Yep. Another question. You
were mentioning this kind of
view, we'll be doing the
condominium, that fiscal explanation,
the deck,
the foundation of where we stand
with time as we move forward.
Uh, but there is like a physical sense
where you can put that can Arrow of time,
the, these all the sons, all of
entropy like university validity.
So they're just like an
objective physical sense.
You can say that the pain that
moves forward not kind of,
so in the block universe,
everything is already laid out,
but there's still an Arrow of time.
Um,
because there's a forward Arrow in which
things go one way and not the other way.
As you probably know,
the laws of physics are time asymmetric.
You can run Newton's equations or
Einstein's equations or even Schrodinger's
equation, forwards or
backwards. There's no time.
So the typical explanation
to address the Arrow,
the Arrow of time is as you
brought up the entropic era,
that entropy increases now and to
be by itself doesn't explain there.
What it does is just say
it provides any symmetry.
The real explanation comes from the fact
that the universe seems to have started
in a state of low entropy.
And from there it can only go up.
But the tricky thing about entropy is if
I say there's a state of medium entropy
here that predicts that the next
time step it should be higher.
But if you think about it,
it also predicts that the previous
time step should be higher.
So then tropic Arrow is sometimes
called the bi directional arrow.
That doesn't explain the
ire of time by itself.
It needs to be coupled with an
assumption about a lower initial stage.
Um,
so first of all,
and I'm not saying this to person
who anyone, but I'm an atheist,
but when I look at the, uh, the, uh,
eternalism worldview that
block the lock world, you know,
we can look at a person
as a baby in a person,
as an adult and practically or all or
all cells have their body have since died
and been replaced. They are, and there's,
that's a topic in itself like what makes
me me like, like I feel like design, but,
but if I look at the block universe,
um, as, as you depicted it, um,
and say, okay, space and time is all there
is and, and, and it all exists already,
then it brings about a philosophical
question of what links the slice where I
was a baby in this slice,
where I'm in the adult to create a
consciousness that views both as the same
thing. Right? So it almost suggests
bend the additional layer. No,
no, no. I think you, the question of
consciousness is perplexing either way,
whether what makes you you or makes
me mean what consciousness is.
I think that's a dilemma. A challenge to
science, whether you're participating,
whether you subscribe to the turtles,
fewer the present dispute, right?
Consciousness.
We can't explain either way.
But I think there's a
further challenge of,
um,
posed by the journalist view when it
comes to consciousness in terms of if
things aren't flowing,
changing in a dynamic fashion,
why do we have this clear, distinct
feeling? And more importantly,
what's the evolutionary
function of feeling time
change if there's no correlate
with the actual universe, it's not like
something we perceive color, right?
Color is the creation of the human mind,
right?
Because there's no color
in the physical world.
There's wavelengths of electromagnetic
radiation. We interpret that as color,
but that has a very strong adaptive value.
So there's a there. So the question is,
is if we see if we feel time flowing,
but it actually doesn't,
what's that function from
an evolutionary perspective?
And I think that's the mystery
that will probably have for awhile.
Hi. Thanks for coming. Uh,
so what's the difference between the
mental time travel and like fantasy,
uh, you know, like telling
myself a story about the future.
What I mean is like an example is I could
tell myself a story that I will go to
the store later and it will be
open. Um, but that might not be so,
so is there like a probability
element wrapped up in there or,
I think the question,
interesting question is,
could we even have stories if we
couldn't have mental time travel?
Can other animals have stories?
And whether that story takes place in
the future or the present or the past,
right? You haven't gone later on and
we're going to go to the museum. Um,
and so is that a story?
Is that a plan or is that a fiction?
So what makes humans unique,
I believe is that what makes us creative
is this fine line between stories and
reality.
So if,
if I'm primitive man and it's
a story, oh, I wish I could,
um, hunt down a, um, a mammoth,
you know, is that a story? But then
you're thinking, well, if I had a weapon,
maybe I could.
So this marriage of the stories and
reality I think is probably what's driving
much of our technology and creativity
is this very delicate balance between
getting the stories just so
that it sounds like fiction,
but it's fiction we can create
in the future. Sure. Yeah.
I would just say we're almost
always wrong. Absolutely.
Until we've seen a repeatable
path. That sounds good. I,
I certainly feel that
I'm almost always wrong,
I assume pumped and people are
often right. But, um, yeah,
I mean there's trial and error and
stochasticity in there. Absolutely.
And we can't know in advance. It's so,
so if the future hasn't been laid out,
clearly we don't have access to it.
All right. Thanks. You're welcome.
Thanks so much for, this is great. Thank
you. Um, are you familiar with the, um,
Donald Hoffman? No. Uh, he's,
um, he's like a physicist,
philosopher. He's got interesting
theories about consciousness.
The fact is I'm probably
gonna Butcher this theory,
but I think essentially it's that
consciousness is the base of reality and
everything else was like on top of it.
So he claims to have proven that,
uh,
what is it?
Like everything we know,
everything we see is just based on like
is this will be reconstructed because it
was evolutionary missionary adaptable.
It was like a good thing for us.
Do you think time could be
something similar to that?
So there's this very interesting debate
about whether time is so some fields or
hypotheses and physics are
trying to get rid of time.
So say that time doesn't exist.
Um,
and what this means is that
time is not a property.
They're not saying that time
clock time doesn't exist.
What they're saying is that time isn't
a fundamental property of the universe.
It's not like energy or matter.
Um,
and that time is simply an abstraction
of creation of the human mind.
The way earn smock put this
is it's utterly impossible
to measure change by time
because time is an abstraction at
which we arrive at by measuring change.
And that's indeed what clocks do.
All clocks are, or just some way,
some device that conveniently
standardize is change.
Whether that changes swinging of a
pendulum. Mark Clark, quartz crystal.
So I the the subjective feeling of time,
I think I've,
I've started with all the way expressed.
It's unknown, but the concept of time,
I think I,
I do like the idea that it's
an abstraction that we've
created that's incredibly
useful to help us understand the
universe and make sense of the world,
but it's not a fundamental
property of physics.
Um,
thanks for this talk by the way.
I had some questions about your thoughts
on how are our relative conceptions of
time are limited by physical
like dendrites, axons,
physical barriers.
So in a world where we are able to
create artificial intelligence or even
potentially upload our own consciousness
or replicate our consciousness in a
world which isn't limited
by dendrites and axons,
uh Ha have you w what are your thoughts
on being able to extend our concepts of
time because of those physical barriers
being removed for slowing down?
So a real person is existing.
There's an AI which
experiences at thousand years
of time because they're able
to process information faster.
There's, there's a couple of issues there.
So those are, those are deep questions.
I mean, one is the hardware
question, right? Is,
is consciousness and our
subjective experience of time,
hardware dependent hardware limited,
can you create ais that have um,
consciousness totally equivalent to ours?
So that's a question that of course
nobody knows the answer to. I mean,
as a materialist,
I certainly believe there's no reason
that consciousness has to be hardware
limited.
Now that question however,
is different from the question
of speed of processing, right?
So this question of sampling rate,
um,
in which the speed of processing
is ultimately independent of our,
the notion of the passage of time,
you're processing signals that coming
from my speech that you're doing that
right now that are far beyond the,
your subjective experience,
the passage of time.
So the brain clearly processes things
that are happening very quickly like this.
That's microseconds.
Your brain detects that.
So even though they're made of
neurons, it's incredible feat, right?
Neurons have a time constant
of maybe an action potential.
So if you going to give
it a computer clock, ray,
you'd probably give it a kilo hertz
instead of a couple of hundred
Gigahertz, for example. So then, um,
so that time level of
processing is different from
the time level of subjective
experiences.
Now nobody knows the answer to the
question of whether an AI would,
um,
be able to have these temporal distortions
of conscious experiences like you or
I have. But I think, I think there's,
in a way it's the wrong question.
I think the mystery is not so much
how time comes to be distorted,
how are in extreme cases of time,
dilation or time compression.
But what our normal sense of time is,
and I view this is just the flexibility
of conscience. Your conscience.
You can be time conscious
of a short period of time
or long term period of time.
That's just a conscious state.
It's just a flavor of consciousness,
just like pain or pleasure or color.
So I think that when we understand
the nature of consciousness,
the question of whether
it seems long or short,
we'll be sort of a minor
issue along those lines.
Because I think what we
perceive is a bit arbitrary.
Just the quick notes
where a bit or two pls.
Let's not add more questions if you're
already in line as your questions.
Thank you all here. Um, uh,
I want to ask about what is the difference
or are they the same thing for the
things like a retrospective
retrospective thing? He,
and so I'll talk about
graphic memory or x originals.
Back to thinking about a general loss of
memory or just some things about myself
in the past.
Yes, that's a good question. So, um,
autobiographical memory
or episodic memory is, um,
about events in our own knife and
that's tightly coupled to how we
retrospectively perceived time.
So if there's a period of time,
whichever rich autobiographical
memory I did this, this,
this, this, this, and this,
that's likely to elicit a
long estimate of time. Um,
whereas if you don't have any events in
memory, um, that's a short period of time.
The extreme example of this
is somebody who has amnesia.
So you can imagine if somebody has no
ability to form new episodic memories are
autobiographical memories,
how could they even estimate
the power of time has elapsed?
So there's this very touching,
poignant case of a British
man called Clive wearing,
and you've maybe some of you have seen,
I'm specials on him,
but he has terrible anterograde Amnesia
and he believes he seems to be locked
into the present. And there's a story
where he's writing in his diary,
9:00 AM I just woke up nine 30,
now I'm awake for the first time,
10 o'clock now, now I'm really
awake for the time. Right.
Because if you don't have that memory,
how can you know how much time has
elapsed so clearly, retrospectively,
time and memory are tightly coupled.
Yeah.
Um, so as you said, uh,
all of our time keeping devices rely
on oscillators or rely on some kind of
notion of periodicity.
And so, um, kind of,
I guess my question is like,
if you,
so if you look at an oscillation
or assigned waiver, any
sort of, um, you know, any,
any sort of phenomenon that
you can understand that way,
there's a notion of symmetry that's
really important that, you know,
you could be at one point and,
um,
and it's also [inaudible] or it can be
at the exact same point and then another
period later. So it gives you kind
of that, that eternal perspective.
What if that didn't exist? So, you know,
like how would we measure time if we
didn't have this sort of repeatable,
you mean you mean manmade time,
right? Clock time, you mean?
Well,
I guess what I'm asking is like,
is there something fundamental about
the idea of like periodicity or no,
I never, well, I'm just
like, yeah, how was it?
It wasn't something that was symmetric
that we could always kind of stuff.
So, no, I don't think so. I think
it sits just reproducibly, I mean,
you can measure time by,
um,
an hourglass is something that's not,
doesn't have to be periodic.
So I think manmade clocks,
um,
rely on this mechanism because it's an
incredibly useful, symmetric one. Right?
And it's the best way to
do something continuously.
These with periodically
something that's periodic,
but you need some sophisticated counter.
And that was really the main problem.
But if you look, even if
you look at something like,
um, planetary motion, right?
You can tell the time of year by
looking at the position. Yeah,
I've been with an hourglass. You could
turn it off. Like there's a kind of,
but you don't have to,
you can't, you can, but you
don't have to write. Um,
you could have a non periodic
hourglass. So I think, um,
periodicity is something
that in our minds,
because of the success of manmade clocks
is something we naturally think of as
the ideal way to tell time. And
it probably is, but interestingly,
and I think there's a downside to that,
which is people spent a bit too much
time looking for those oscillators,
encounters in the brain. And I think
that through the field off the bit,
because that's probably not how the brain
tells time. Yes, brain has oscillators,
but it doesn't seem to have
many oscillator counter
system. So I think these,
these metaphors we use in the
external world sometimes. Um,
can you put us back a bit when we're
overly influenced by them? Thank you.
Thank you. Thanks everybody for
coming and thanks dean. Thanks.
Yeah.